FEED O O
SCORES!
THE JACKETS CORE WIWIGREAT LOOK.
MAX KNOWS
GUY.
HE'S TAKEN A LOT OF NOTES THE
LAST SIX YEARS AND HE'S READY
FOR
TRYING TO GET THAT PARK LOOKS OD
IT'S OUT OF PLAY
SAVES THAT UP THE LINE. GOALS. .
HE WILL DROP IT THERE, IT'S
PICK
THE VETERAN PLAYER HERE PICKED
KELLER, CAN'T GET TO IT.
WERENSKI AND
COMBED DOWN.
THERE IS A
PAST THE MIDWAY POINT, SECOND
THE
LAST SECOND.MILING.
HERE'S THE SAY THAT THE OTHER
END.
ELVIS
LIGHT OF THE CROWD.
JACKETS MOVIVI THEIR WAY
IN THE SECOND PERIOD, TIRE
DEFENDERS OUT KEPT
IN A PIE.
GOOD WORK TH DEFENSE.
TIMMINS ADVANCIN PARK AFTER TRYO
CONDUCTOR AND EVERYTHING GOES
THROUGH HIM, BUT IN ERICKSON.
FEW TIMES.
THE SHIFT BEFORE, THOSE GUYS INL
HOCKEY LEAGUE.
A SHOT THAT IS
A VETERAN PLAYER WHO, COMING
INTO THIS G G